ηλεκτρονικών έγκλημα είναι οποιο τι δήποτε παράνομες προσβάσειτς γίνονται μέσα του διαδεικτύου υπάρχει και τίποτο
δημοκατάλογος μπορώεί να αγοράσεισς παραδή μο συχάρη και υπηρεσίες ο πρόεδρος και στο δουλίδης ήταν
το μοναδικό άτομο που απειλήθηκε στα όσα χρόνια βρίσκεστα στο λεκτωμικό έγκλημα ύυπήρξαν και άλλοι
πολιτική που δεχθηκαν ναπλημικά μηματακαλύθεπου μαζικά μηνήματα ακριβό υτά τα μηνήματα λέγονται φύσι δηλαδή όποιο
συμπίσει που υπάρχουν αυτί οι οποί πως παφούν να αντλήσουν οι λικόν από παιδιά επώ
στην κύπρ και αυτή ήταν αυτό που γύρισε κάποιος να πει που συνελήθει για ποιαδική
πορνογραφεία και σε εβγαλε με κτόσπαραδέκτεε ο αγήλιος ότι το άλλο πεδάκερι που είχε της
εξολιγή ηλεκρινά σκοτείνιαζα όλα η μικρινά είχαπές σε απότα σύνεπα ήα πολύ ο χαριστικόκιλές και
κύρί άλλοντα έαλλά εκποτκα σήμερα μαζί σας θα δούμε ένα διαφρωτικό θεμα σήμερα το λεκτρονικό
έγκλημα σκοτινόδιαδείκτυο απειλές και απάτες αρμόδιος για να το συζηνήσουμε αυτό το θέμα προιστάμερο υπό
διευθυση λεκτρονικό εγκλήματος ο κύριος αντρέας αναστασιάδης και να στασιάδει θα σα συλερατό και ευχαριστώμε
αποδεχθηκα την πρώμοείμάστε στη διάδισς είνα πράγματι έναν πολύ επίπεδον θέμα το ηλεκτρωνικώδενκλημα αλλά κι
τοτη συμπετη το διαδείκτο με πάρα πολλες τυές καιαυτό που χρεάζετα καταλάβωμε είναι ότι δε
είναι μόνο ηπτυχεί του ηλεκτρονικού εγκλήματος διλαδή ι παράνουμες προσβάσεις αλλά ένα σε βρείς θέμα
το ολογία μεγάλη να κάνουμε αρχή με αυτή το πιές είναι οημορφές του λεκτρονικού